a subdued orthodox easter at churches
throughout ukraine also marking two
months since the start of the russian
invasion
we heard air raid sirens after mass says
this priest it's tragic that people who
call themselves christian do such things
they didn't even stop on the biggest
celebration in the world the
resurrection of christ elsewhere no
services at all churches like this one
which survived the second world war now
no longer a place of refuge or prayer
russian president vladimir putin marked
the holiday at a church in moscow
while ukraine's president vowed
wickedness would not destroy the country
in an easter message delivered in a 1
000 year old keeve cathedral volodymir
zelensky says the u.s secretary of state
and defense secretary were to visit kyv
sunday the first official visit by u.s
officials since russia invaded ukraine
calling for more weapons money and
sanctions it's very important when
our partners go to ukraine to see by
their own eyes what's happened
which atrocities and war crimes russian
army and russian federation made in
ukraine this week the un secretary
general is also set to visit turkey
moscow and kiev though many are doubtful
there can be a diplomatic solution right
now i don't think the situation on the
battlefield yet lends itself to some
sort of diplomatic compromise solution
both sides still
imagine that they can win this the
biggest battle mariupol ukraine says
civilians and soldiers are still holed
up under the giant steel plant now
facing russian bombs and while
humanitarian corridors so far have not
been successful hundreds of people
were gathered
at one point to to go out of madrupo and
russian soldiers just came and said no
we're not allowing this to happen sunday
ukraine proposed a special round of
negotiations in the city to discuss the
fate of those trapped while russia has
repeatedly denied killing civilians
abigail beeman global news washington